il s'agit d'une anomalie de la
température de surface de l'océan dans
le pacifique
habituellement c'est ce qu'on voit sur
ce schéma les vents dominants sur le
pacifique sont des alizés qui pousse les
eaux les deux surfaces les plus chaudes
vers l'ouest et puis la situation et
niño où on voit que les zones en rouge
se sont décalées vers le centre et l'est
du pacifique
donc les températures les plus chaudes
autour de 26 à 32 et se retrouve
maintenant beaucoup plus à l'est la
contrepartie côté atmosphère c'est que
au dessus de ses eaux les plus chaudes
il y a aussi les orages les plus
violents
la convection donc les mouvements
verticaux les plus forts et les
précipitations les plus forts tous les
el niño ne se valent pas nul n'ignore on
va dire classique veut pas dépasser 1,5
degré le celui 90 1996-98 est arrivé à
2,3 2,5 degrés en suivant la région de
comprend résultat une saison cyclonique
exceptionnel au dessus du pacifique
ouragans cyclones ou typhon quel que
soit le nom qu'on leur donne en fonction
de la zone où elles se produisent ces
tempêtes ou bouillonnante ont battu
plusieurs records dans les tempêtes
tropicales
dès que le vent dépasse ce seuil de 120
kilomètres heure on les passe en
catégorie cyclone en deçà entre 120 et
60 kilomètres heure c'est une tempête
tropicale est encore en dessous c'est
une dépression tropicale
donc en général on prend en charge en
prévision le phénomène dès qu'il atteint
le stade de dépression tropicale ont
commencé à être vigilants sur le
phénomène
et quand il atteint le
le seuil de tempête tropicale donc c'est
à dire 60 kilomètres heure on lui donne
un nom qui permettra ensuite de le
suivre de manière plus simple
el niño se manifeste donc par un
réchauffement hors du commun des eaux de
surface à l'est du pacifique
md fitch avait dans le futur les eaux de
surface vont être plus chaud et
l'intensité des tempêtes est directement
liée à la température des eaux qu'elle
traverse
dans les prévisions sur les
comportements des ouragans était typhon
dans le futur il y a beaucoup d'études
qui ne sont pas tous d'accord d'ailleurs
mais elle suggère tout que les tempêtes
pourraient être moins nombreuses mais
plus intenses et si le réchauffement
climatique se combinait avec un el niño
très fort
les effets de l'un et de l'autre
serait-il démultipliée
c'est un scénario sur lequel la science
n'a pas encore suffisamment de recul
mais qui fait l'objet de nombreuses
recherches l'un jouant climatique
amplifie dira pas que pour un mignon
pour l'ensemble de la planète amplifie
les phénomènes extrêmes qui hésite de
façon naturelle placer la conjonction de
du changement climatique chaque année ça
se réchauffe un peu plus et d'el niño
on a vu que ninio c'est un car a fait un
quart de la surface de la planète
donc quand il ya un degré de
réchauffement dall'igna 0,1 degré et les
conséquences à venir del niño ne se
limiterait pas aux seules pacifique
ce mécanisme météorologique est l'un des
plus puissants moteurs de changement du
climat mondial
c'est pas du tout aussi localiser qui
pourrait y paraître vue de l'europe en
fait c'est que au niveau des tropiques
on a déjà la moitié de la surface du
globe qui se trouve entre 30° nord et 30
degrés sud en plus l'océan pacifique
c'est vraiment un monstre au niveau au
niveau océans sur la planète
jusque on a dix-sept mille kilomètres
des côtes de l'amérique du sud jusqu'à
aux philippines de l'autre côté
el niño est loin d'avoir dit son dernier
mot